[Música]
k
Olá boa noite minhas amigas meus amigos
sejam muito bem-vindos como vai
Cristina por favor me diga como está o
áudio Boa noite
Alexandre a medida que vocês forem
entrando por favor me vão dando o
feedback do
áudio temos algumas perguntas para
responder hoje e três artigos para a
gente conversar a respeito
bem deixa eu aqui
separar as perguntas pra gente
discutir Parece que tem uma pergunta de
última hora aqui deixa eu acrescentar
ela
tá dando para lei bem isso aqui
[Música]
não a primeira pergunta é se a nova
vacina pneumo 20 é
segura e ela foi feita pela ru Elita
bem eu dei uma pesquisada sobre essa
vacina pineo 20 e pelas Fontes oficiais
ela teria um perfil de segurança
bom foi confirmada por estudos clínicos
de fase TR ao contrário que aconteceu
com a vacina do
c19 ela é uma vacina da tecnologia
convencional ela é uma vacina feita com
constituintes inativado das bactérias
ela é feit com polissacarídeos das
paredes das bactérias então ela não
contém nem bactéria viva e nem contém
RNA mensageiro ou qualquer outra coisa
que induza modificações
genéticas e os efeitos colaterais mais
comuns dessa pemo 20 em crianças é
irritabilidade sonolência
dor no local da injeção diminuição do
apetite elit tema que a vermelhidão no
local da injeção e febre já em adultos
os sintomas mais comuns é dor no local
da injeção dor muscular fadiga e dor de
cabeça sempre é importante lembrar que
qualquer vacina que você for tomar é
interessante utilizar a vitamina D que
ela esteja pelo menos 50 entre 50 70 no
sangue para você poder ter a melhor
reação possível à vacina
e verificar o seu nível de zinco no
organismo se tiver baixo tem que repor
zinco e se preocupar que ter uma
alimentação rica em
antioxidantes vegetais verdes escuros
frutas
cítricas sono adequado e manejo do
estresse falando um pouco mais sobre a
vacina ela emprega um sistema de
conjugação que utiliza uma proteína
chamada
crm197 que é carreadora e essa proteína
tá ligada a
polissacarídeos capsulares do
streptococus pneumoni que é a bactéria e
essa conjugação transforma os
polissacarídeos em antígenos dependentes
células T isso traria uma Resposta imune
mais robusta E
duradora então esses polissacarídeos
capsulares vem de 20 sorotipos
diferentes do streptoc pneumoni
ela então não tem nenhuma bactéria viva
não tem RNA mensageiro e não tem DNA
também então até onde eu pude
ver essa vacina é segura
sim Cristina tá dizendo que o som tá ok
ah Maria Helena que entrou Roberta por
favor também me deu um um feedback por
gentileza e o Alexandre por favor se
puder dar o feedback do áudio Eu
agradeceria tá Vamos paraa segunda
pergunta qual que é o valor ideal do T3
reverso O ideal que o T3 reverso esteja
no primeiro quartil ou no máximo no
segundo
quartil o que que é o T3 reversa ele é
um hormônio produzido
naturalmente ele é uma forma de do
organismo converter o T4 uma forma
inativa quando o organismo sofrer uma
lesão muito grande precisa entrar numa
espécie de hibernação para ter a
Regeneração então ele é um hormônio que
tem função biológica por exemplo se você
tiver internado numa UTI o organismo
pega o T4 e converte em T3 reverso ao
invés de converter em T3 livre para
organismo diminuir a atividade
metabólica então ele é
considerado um
metabólito inativo ele serve Então como
regulador nessas situações que eu acabei
de
falar na medicina funcional a gente se
preocupa no valor isolado Mas também se
preocupa com a relação em T3 reverso T3
livre o valor ideal Como eu disse é
primeiro
quartil a maioria dos laboratórios
considera os valores entre 8 e
25 então a gente quer que ele fique
abaixo de 18 se esse laboratório em
questão utilizar
essas medidas entre 8 e 25 Então tem que
tá no primeiro
quartil valores excessivamente Altos de
T3 reversos podem indicar uma conversão
inadequada de T4 em T3 livre e podem
gerar o
hipotiroidismo isso tá relacionado a
estresse crônico
deficiências nutricionais como falta de
selênio Inc ferro
inflamação dietas restritivas doenças
crônicas é importante para reequilibrar
os valores do T3 reverso tá
com níveis desses micronutrientes
adequados reduzir o estresse com técnica
de meditação
relaxamento corrigir a vitamina D de
dado regir o
magnésio se for
necessário e em muitos casos se tiver
acompanhamento médico fazer a
suplementação com T3
bioidêntico Ok então primeiro quartil se
o laboratório for entre 8 e 25 você quer
que o seu T3 esteja até 15 entre 8 e 15
o T3 reverso que eu tô falando
próxima pergunta obrigado pelo feedback
Maria Helena Alexandre e
Roberta semente de chia contém
nutrientes contém antinutrientes net
fala que
não net falar que não é é muito genérico
né pessoal a internet inteira falar que
não
eh bem genérico isso daí mas mas é o
fato é que tem sem antinutrientes tá a
chia é nutritiva ela é rica em fibras
Ela tem ômega-3 ela tem minerais Mas tem
sim antinutrientes e quais seriam Esses
antinutrientes são os fitatos ou ácidos
fí que podem reduzir temporariamente a
absorção de certos nutrientes como ferro
zinco e cálcio então esses fitatos vão
atrapalhar esse minerais eles se ligam
esses minerais e não deixam eles serem
absorvidos
porém os níveis de antinutrientes que
tem na Chia é considerado baixo
comparado com outras sementes como a
linhaça e geralmente o impacto é baixo O
Impacto é mínimo quando você consome a
chia dentro de níveis aceitáveis sem
comer demais e tem aí métodos simples de
preparo que fazem reduzir ess
antinutrientes quais seriam esses deixar
semente de molho em água por 15 a 30
minutos antes de consumir isso vai
neutralizar parcialmente esses fitatos e
vai otimizar a absorção dos nutrientes
então de modo geral a chia é segura É
benéfica tem potencial antiinflamatório
é uma fonte de ômega-3 importante é uma
fonte importante de minerais e também é
uma fonte importante de
fibras então obviamente o único cuidado
que você tem que ter é não consumir chia
em excesso não consumir quantidades
muito excessivas desse elemento Tá mas
geralmente esses antinutrientes da chia
não são significativos como eu
falei próxima pergunta essa pergunta da
chia foi da Maria
Helena agora a pergunta do Sandro uma
mulher de 45 anos com diagnóstico de
miomatose
endometriose e
adenomiose e que por causa destes tem
hemorragia e anemia indicaram tomar
zoladex injeção para antecipar a
menopausa para não fazer cirurgia qual
sua
opinião então o
zoladex ele é assim um remédio muito
utilizado para
endometriose eu não utilizo o zoladex
como primeira opção eu prefiro usar a
gestrinona que é uma
progestina que a gente tem uma boa
experiência com ela e ela geralmente
resolve as endometriose se ela não for
uma endometriose muito grave só com a
progestina já deve ser o
suficiente bem falando um pouquinho
sobre essas
condições a endometriose e adenomiose
são duas faes da mesma doença que é o
depósito anormal de tecido endometrial
quando é no caso no músculo do útero a
gente chama de adenomiose quando é for
da cavidade uterina a gente chama de
endometriose já a miomatose é quando se
formam tumores
benignos na parede do útero que pode ser
subseroso
submucoso é como se fosse uma bola de
carne que se forma na parede do útero
que quando ela ela baula pro lado da
mucosa do útero ela faz sangramento e
quando ela abula pro lado de fora ela
não chega a dar sangramento mas pode dar
dor e desconforto sensação de peso tanto
o mioma quanto a endometriose a
adenomiose elas são condições
relacionadas ao excesso de estrogênio
predominância ou dominância
estrogênica e também relacionada a
inflamação crônica e os principais
sintomas no caso do mioma como eu falei
sensação de peso e sangramento que pode
levar anemia e na endometriose e na
adenomiose é mais comum dor intensa
durante a
menstruação pelo fato do tecido
endometrial tá sangrando pro lado
errado o zoladex é o acetato de
goserelina ele é um bloqueador ele é um
agonista seletivo na verdade ele é um
agonista
parcial do LH ele é um medicamento que
acaba bloqueando a produção de hormônio
ele vai suprimir a produção de
estrogênio e induzir uma Men Men pausa
temporária Enquanto você tiver
utilizando também ele é utilizado para
câncer de próstata Então os zoladex vai
reduzir o sangramento vai aliviar o
sintomas a curto prazo mas o uso
prolongado vai trazer efeitos colaterais
como perda óssea Fogás ou calorão e
alteração de
humor e o zoladex ele não vai curar a
doença El não vai resolver a causa
subjacente né que é o desequilíbrio
hormonal e a inflamação Então dentro
medicina funcional como eu falei eu
prefiro usar gestrinona que vai ter esse
efeito também antiestrogênicos vai ter
um leve efeito androgênico e vai ter um
efeito anti progesterona também mas eu
acho ele muito mais suave que os
zoladex e ele também ajuda a ganhar
massa muscular em mulheres então eu
usaria muito
mais a gestrinona Ok E além disso tem
que optar por uma estratégia temporária
além da estratégia de você bloquear o
hormônio que é uma estratégia temporária
seja com zoladex ou com gestrinona você
optar por uma estratégia de longo prazo
que é a a causa tratar a causa do
desequilíbrio hormonal a inflamação e a
saúde intestinal então uma das coisas
que funcionam bem É o detox hepático
porque o fígado ele processa a
metabolização do
estrogênio você promoveu equilíbrio
entre estrogênio e progesterona então
depois de você tirar a gestrinona você
pode entrar com progesterona base
bioidêntica para fazer esse reequilíbrio
entre esses dois entar com de indol
metano indol escabin que são substâncias
que vão melhorar a metilação e
o detox do
estrogênio tirar as toxinas ambientais
os ruptores endc ou seja eliminar o
plástico da
cozinha rever o os cosméticos estão
sendo utilizados e trocar os cosméticos
convencionais por cosméticos que sejam
naturais ajuste na dieta como é reduzir
alimentos inflamatórios tirar açúcar
gorduras artificiais aumentar as fibras
o consumo de vegetais crucíferos que é
brócolis couve couve de Bruxelas que são
ricos né que su fora afano que é
antiinflamatório o uso de ômega-3 também
tem efeito antiinflamatório você pode
utilizar também óleo de borragem e óleo
de
ã tem o borrade e o outro também que é
omega6 que é o gama linolênico é o óleo
de prímula tá óleo de borragem e óleo de
prímula que ajuda a modular os hormônios
junto com
omega-3 e também você pode utilizar o
cálcio de glucarato que é uma substância
que tira o estrogênio do intestino e
impede a recirculação entérica desse
elemento
e pra anemia é importante você repor o
ferro seja com medicamento seja
utilizando alimentos ezem ferro como é o
caso o fígado fígado de galinha é muito
rico em ferro o fígado de boi também
serve carne vermelha Folhas Verdes
escuras uso da vitamina C junto com
ferro para aumentar a
absorção compressas de óleo
de Rin também conhecido como Castor Oil
nome abdômen ajuda a controlar dor a
cutura pode ajudar a controlar a dor da
inflamação pélvica pela
endometriose mioma ou
adenomiose lembrar de dar suporte aos
ossos caso você opte pelo zoladex usando
vitamina D K2 vitamina a Zinco
cobre silício
estrôncio
boro e também uma ingestão adequada de
proteínas
certo próxima
pergunta gosto uma levedura de cerveja
em
pó de bastante de bastante em vitamina
sucos acho que gosta de colocar levedura
de cerveja em vitaminas e sucos passa
para mim uma marca confiável que você
conhece
Tem tempo que eu não uso
levedura de cerveja
hein tem algumas marcas boas
sim mas antes de falar das marcas vamos
falar um pouquinho sobre levedura de
cerveja Ela é Rica em várias vitaminas
no complexo B é uma das
Fontes da natureza mais ricas em
Complexo B tem minerais como Cromo e
selênio tem proteína tem fibra ajuda na
saúde da pele fortalece o sistema de
defesa o sistema imune melhora a energia
melhora o cérebro é fácil adicionar a
várias vitaminas sucos e receitas marcas
confiáveis
temos a gr suplementos é um ar confiável
Nutri Blue que também tem uma omega-3
muito
interessante você tem o vitalin tá deixa
eu colocar essas três marcas aqui no no
chat mas é sempre importante você
verificar o selo da
Anvisa e checar a lista de ingredientes
para ver se você não vai ter alergênicos
começa usando uma colher de chá ao dia
do levedo de cerveja que às vezes ele
pode causar desconfortos digestivos e é
melhor misturar em líquidos
frios deixa eu colocar aqui o no chat as
marcas são essas marcas aqui tá
bem deixa eu ver se tem mais alguma
pergunta
aqui tem mais uma aqui
a respeito do chá das Folhas ficar na
água perguntei ao meu irmão ele não sabe
mas sua explicação de que a substância
dissolvem na
água Eu
descansei Descansou
Como Não entendi isso
não não era aquela pergunta da semana
passada se os nutrientes da folha
voltavam paraa folha e eu respondi que
não
voltavam você tá ao vivo né Maria Helena
tá tá sim você pode explicar o que você
quis dizer com isso aqui
não porque você perguntou semana passada
se os elementos da folha se eles
poderiam voltar paraa folha se deixasse
a folha dentro do chá eu falei que não
e eu não entendi direito que você
escreveu aqui mais sua explicação de que
a substância dissolvem na água Eu
descansei vou esperar você
responder bem vamos para pros artigos
né Tem alguns artigos aqui para discutir
para vocês
bem Tem um estudo recente sobre um
suplemento que eu gosto bastante que eu
uso nas pacientes que T dest
cognitivo que
é eu falei bastante desse suplemento em
vários vídeos anteriores é Ach Ganda a
Ach Ganda é conhecida por turbinar
energia melhorar o humor e também
melhorar a
memória Então esse estudo recente que eu
li sobre a ch Ganda que como vocês sabem
é um
adaptógeno
tradicional e Tem cada vez sido mais
estudado especialmente para saúde mental
e
cognitiva nesse estudo pesquisadores
eles usaram sistema sofisticado chamado
sistema de avaliação desempenho mental
computadorizado e testou os
participantes em cinco áreas cognitivas
memória e atenção entre
elas e também avaliou o humor e a fadiga
Mental para ter uma visão abrangente dos
possíveis benefícios da Chanda então o
estudo reuniu 121 adultos média de idade
de 43 anos eram provinientes da Índia e
da Austrália
de mulheres todas as pessoas estavam
relatando dificuldades de memória
atenção e nível de
energia então é um grupo diverso né de
países bem diferentes Índia e Austrália
Ah eu toquei aqui no microfone sem
querer tirei o
som ele é muito sensível ele tem um
botãozinho aqui eu mexi no microfone e
aí eu bloqueei o
som Austrália [ __ ] vou ter que falar o
artigo inteiro aqui de novo Tá bom agora
você estão escutando
né É muito sensível ele tem um um botão
de toque aqui que é muito sensível eu
acabei tirando o som dele aqui
mas vamos de novo lá tá deixa eu voltar
porque vocês escutaram Austrália então
assim é um estudo de 121 adultos com
idade média de idade 43 anos a maioria
mulheres 60% de mulheres as pessoas
vieram da Índia e da
Austrália todas ess pessoas que estavam
nesse estudo ess 121 adultos tinham
dificuldade de memória atenção ou nível
de energia
baixo então durante 8 semanas ess
participantes tomaram diariamente 600 MG
de extrato de raiz achaga ou
Placebo foam no formato de ensaio
Clínico controlado e randomizado isso
garantiu resultados precisos E
confiáveis então os participantes que
tomaram a chagando tiveram melhoras na
memória episódica na memória de trabalho
na precisão de atenção em comparação com
o grupo
Placebo e também tiveram melhoras no
humor e na redução da Fadiga mental a
única coisa que não variou entre Placebo
e grupo que tomou a Chanda foi a
velocidade de processamento de
informações e aprendizado visoespacial
Então nesse estudo achaga teve um grande
efeito existe estudos anteriores que não
viram esse efeito tão intenso e essa
disparidade na
literatura é explicado pelo desenho dos
estudos anteriores as dosagens variadas
e as características do
participantes que eram também diferentes
e parece que a Chanda vai funcionar
melhor em pessoas mais estressadas então
se for um grupo de pessoas analisadas no
estudo que não tiverem estresse elas
tendem a responder menos a chaga
então dei uma resumida
aqui mas agora o som voltou né
Eliseu até porque tá verde aqui o
marcador do microfone boa noite Eloí
vamos próximo estudo
aqui vamos falar da creatina creatina
vocês conhecem bem é um suplemento muito
utilizado por praticantes de musculação
o pessoal sempre lembra da creatina para
ganho de massa muscular ou para ganho de
força muscular Mas ele tem um efeito
cerebral tem vídeo meu no canal falando
sobre isso tem um estudo recente que
mostra que a creatina pode ser eficaz
para aliviar sintomas de depressão em
pessoas que já estão fazendo terapia
cognitivo
comportamental Então nesse estudo os
pesquisadores investigaram se a
suplementação diária com creatina amono
hidratada poderia melhorar os sintomas
de depressão em adultos e para medir
isso utilizaram um questionário de saúde
do paciente chama
pq9 que é uma ferramenta muito usada
para avaliar a gravidade SAS depressivos
então foram 100 adultos estudados com
idade média de idade 30
anos metade era composta por homens e
outra metade por mulheres E todos foram
diagnosticados com transtorno depressivo
maior gravidade Vando variando de leve a
severa e não haviam tomado medicamentos
psicotrópicos nas oito semanas
anteriores ao estudo então eles estavam
livres de antidepressivos e outras
coisas que poderiam tá interferindo no
estudo tá todos eram da Índia então o
estudo durou o8 semanas foi randomizado
e controlado ou seja foi um estudo bem
desenhado os participantes foram
divididos em dois grupos um grupo que
tomou 5 g de creatina monohidratada
diariamente enquanto o grupo tomou outro
grupo tomou Placebo que é pilo de
farinha então ambos os grupos passaram
por cinco sessões de 45 minutos de
terapia cognitivo comportamental durante
o período do estudo e os resultados os
sintomas de depressão melhoraram Em
ambos os grupos mas o grupo que tomou
creatina apresentou uma melhora
significativamente maior e a diferença
foi clinicamente relevante indicando que
a maioria dos participantes no grupo da
creatina sentiu uma melhora perceptível
na
condição Quais são as fontes da creatina
na alimentação ela é encontrada em
carnes vermelhas em peixes mas ela
também é produzida no corpo
principalmente no fígado no zins e no
cérebro e ela é muito importante como se
fosse uma bateria ela armazena
energia ela armazena grupos fosfatos de
Alta Energia e elas são utilizadas em
momento de exercício de muita força de
explosão regenerando o ATP mas também é
utilizado para funcionamento ideal das
células
cerebrais nós sabemos que todas as
doenças neurodegenerativas e também
transtornos psiquiátricos têm problema
de formação de ATP no
cérebro a depressão também tá incluo
nisso aí então a depressão tem também
problemas relacionados à produção de ATP
no
cérebro então estudos sugerem que a
suplementação creatina pode aumentar os
níveis no cérebro dessa substância
melhorando assim a bioenergética
cerebral e aliviando sintomas de
depressão tem evidência que a creatina
pode modular receptores de
neurotransmissores como dopamina e no
serotonina e reduzir o estresse
oxidativo e esse mecanismo poderia I
ajudar a explicar os possíveis efeitos
antidepressivos modulando dopamina e
serotonina já havia estudos anteriores
Que indicaram benefício da creatina em
em diferentes cenários então em pessoas
por exemplo um transtorno depressivo
maior que tomava antidepressivos a
creatina ajudou a potencializar
amplificar os efeitos dos
antidepressivos porém os resultados
acabam variando de acordo com o desenho
do estudo e também com a
dose Então esse estudo reforça a ideia
de que a creatina ajuda na depressão
pode ser uma elemento adjuvante além de
ser uma substância que vai melhorar o
funcionamento cerebral de modo geral
Então vai ser eficaz para ajudar a
melhorar a depressão Especialmente
quando você combina ela com terapias
como é o caso da cognitivo
comportamental é uma solução promiss mas
tem necessidade de mais estudos de alta
qualidade para confirmar entender melhor
esses
efeitos e vocês já usaram
creatina Qual a experiência que vocês
tiveram com creatina e me falem também o
uso que vocês tiveram da Chanda tá
bom antes de esperar você responder
sobre a Chanda e sobre Vamos pro próximo
estudo Esse estudo aqui ele avaliou o
consumo de bebidas zero álcool entre
adolescentes existe uma preocupação
crescente entre
especialistas Porque existe
uma fatia desses especialistas que estão
acreditando que o uso dessas bebidas
zero álcool estão estimulando
adolescentes a começar a beber bebidas
mais pesadas com álcool Ok existe
algumas pessoas que defendem que as
bebidas sem álcool poderia promover
comportamento mais saudável enquanto os
outros que eu já falei que temem que
funciona que funcione né Essas bebidas
sem álcool como um portal pro consumo de
bebidas alcoólicas teve um estudo
recente que discutiu os potenciais
impactos dessas bebidas no comportamento
dos jovens Então os pesquisadores
analisaram os hábitos de consumo de mais
de 600 adolescentes entre 15 a 17 anos
na
Austrália 600 adolescentes 15 a 17 anos
Austrália cerca de um terço já tinha
experimentado essas bebidas sem álcool
sendo que metade
recebeu essas bebidas dos pais ou
responsáveis Além disso os adolescentes
que consumiam álcool tinham o dobro de
chance de ter
experimentado a bebida sem álcool e
vice-versa
sugerindo uma relação entre os dois
comportamentos Então os dados revelam
que essas bebidas estão se tornando
populares entre os jovens quatro em cada
cinco
adolescentes lembraram ter visto essas
bebidas à venda e quase um terço
considerou
comprá-las e esses jovens estão
considerando essas bebidas como um
recurso para se encaixar em situações
sociais onde os outros mais velhos estão
consumindo
álcool por outro lado alguns
participantes acreditam que essas
bebidas podem aumentar a curiosidade
sobre o álcool ou seja ele pode começar
tomando isso para acompanhar os adultos
que estão tomando álcool e com o tempo
esse adolescente poderia querer tomar o
próprio álcool a Bida alcoólica isso
tornaria a transição para bebidas alco
algo mais natural então houve um estudo
japonês de 2018 que tinha apontado já
que adolescentes que experimentam essas
bebidas sem álcool Demonstra o maior
interesse em iniciar o uso de bebidas
alcoólicas então tem uma psiquiatra
infantil chamada lisa
durete ela sugere que alternativas ao
álcool poderiam incentivar esses
comportamentos mais saudáveis em
ambientes sociais
tem opinião contrária ela não acredita
que esses esse essas bebidas seriam
problemáticas no entanto outro
pesquisador que é o Leon Buff que é o
autor principal do
estudo ele Alerta que a familiarização
com hábito de beber poderia incentivar o
interesse em bebidas alcoólicas
especialmente em culturas onde o álcool
é
mais parte da cultura local né como se é
o caso da
país aí do leste europeu a Rússia né E
até no caso do Brasil né que o álcool é
muito parte da nossa
cultura mais de 50% dos adolescentes que
consumiram essas bebidas sem álcool
receberam essas bebidas em casa muitas
vezes pelos pais que eram mais
permissivos em relação ao consumo de
álcool e Estudos anteriores mostraram
que atitudes relaxadas dos cuidadores
podem levar ao comportamentos de maior
risco no futuro então tá essa polêmica
aí né E esse estudo fala que eles acham
que realmente essas bebidas tipo cerveja
sem álcool são
problemáticas vocês têm uma opinião
sobre esse assunto vocês têm casos que
vocês conhecem de adolescentes que
comearam a usar por
exemplo cerveja sem ácool e depois isso
estimulou o consumo de álcool Qual que é
a opinião de vocês
tem uma pergunta do Eliseu aqui creatina
combina bem com binol combina combina
bem um conhecido tomou binol e a dor da
herne de disco sumiu tem alguma
explicação não não tenho explicação pode
ter sido coincidência
sim na minha cabeça agora pensando aqui
não não consigo pensar no mecanismo de
ação do bikol
para parar a dor da a de
disco você diz que pessoas estressadas
respondem melhor a chagando do que
pessoas não estressadas isso mas se o
objetivo for o fortalecimento da memória
ambas respondem igualmente parece que a
pessoa não estressada responde menos a
chaga do que a estressada isso que os
estudos têm
sugerido
Eliseu não que não vai funcionar para
fortalecer a memória mas as mais
estressadas vão ser mais
beneficiadas Tomara Ach gana de manhã
cerveja Talvez seja ruim porque vai
baixar o cortisol depende
Eliseu Depende de como é que tá o
cortial da
pessoa e de manhã é bom que o corol
esteja alto não alto demais é bom que
esteja
alto dentro da faixa normal
nunca usei creatina fiz exame essa
semana sobre creatina não é a creatinina
aí você tá falando Maria Helena é
creatinina tá o exame que você fez é
creatinina e o suplemento é creatina é
bem parecido mesmo tá
Aero ao ler o artigo sobre a chagando
você disse que as pessoas tomaram dose
de 600 MG essa dose é boa para chagando
fortalecer memória sim é
boa para ajudar a dormir o melhor
horário para tomar chagando é à noite
sim é o melhor horário é à noite antes
de
deitar para fortalecer a memória tanto
faz o horário sim é é essa que é a
situação
Eliseu bem pessoal isso que eu tinha
hoje para apresentar pro para
vocês mais
perguntas deixa eu ver se tem mais
alguma pergunta aqui no no
documento não não tem mais
não não tem mais perguntas
Boa pergunta aqui a chagando a baixa
pressão de forma indireta sim porque se
você tiver com cortisol alto pode
aumentar a pressão e a ch Ganda baixando
o cortisol pode secundariamente baixar a
pressão arterial
tá então de maneira indireta pode S
baixar a pressão arterial mas não
muito quando diz na embalagem que A
levedura de cerveja tem B12 será que é
B12 adicionado não é B12 do da levedura
mesmo
nesse caso seria metil Não
cianocobalamina não é porque a
cianocobalamina é sintética tá não pode
ser cianocobalamina nesse caso
não quando diz na embalagem que A
levedura de cerveja tem Nossa que eu já
respondi
é que você repetiu a
pergunta mais perguntas
pessoal quas tem mais uma aqui não tem
não bem acho que eu vou encerrar Então
tá vou encerrar a
Live e nós nos encontramos novamente
semana que
vem muito obrigado Maria
Helena abraço a todos vocês Até semana
que
vem n